oh oh
here he is what's up Noah Michael
Jackson
[Applause]
that's Michael Jackson
[Music]
all right
Sheriff's Department's close by we'll be
safe there okay stay close I'll get you
out of here
oh
my God they got rats they got bread
they didn't get us okay we're still
alive here all right keep it together
yeah okay we gotta make it to the
sheriff station
[Music]
oh my God
[Music]
we gotta go through them just stay
together keep moving and don't get bit
go
are you getting this what is up all
right let's go
it's
crazy
oh yeah
what
um I don't
[Music]
know
these are some racist [ __ ]
zombies why would you even lock the door
I mean the window's broken and oh
oh hell no no no no no
no
oh
um oh what is that they seriously
wouldn't let her eat us hey guys
isn't this great
these racist zombies are leaving us
alone
come on we having a party
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the newest member of our family will
Feast for the first time
Ophelia
bring the new blood
[Applause]
[Music]
rubber Tyrell
welcome to the first night of your new
end what are we wearing here
I'm just wearing what I got bit in
mm-hmm
okay do you have anything black
or like pants with laces up the side of
the leg to be good just so you can still
see the skin
oh no that's not my style so I ain't got
none of that in my closet or nothing
like that
okay
anyway we will tonight
oh feast
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
excuse me I'm just saying you're over
here looking and hissing and whatnot if
we gonna eat then let's eat damn
yes
of course we will all feed
spread the meats
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
s you know you can make your teeth come
out without doing all that nonsense see
and can you two get a room seriously
y'all live in a damn Mansion they got to
be some other place you could do that I
mean are you two even lesbians
I just don't understand why everything
got to be all sexual and licky girl
seriously man you got to get your hands
up off me before I [ __ ] you up it's
nasty creepiest touching my nipple for
15 minutes did all that y'all is doing
up in here this is just like straight up
gratuitous I got bit on purpose so I
could live forever and see future cars
yeah Cyrus these pants are uncomfortable
and I actually have a boyfriend and this
song has been playing for like two years
and it sucks
oh
it just seems
desperate okay desperate really Tristan
it's Christian
really his name ain't even Tristan so do
you all feel this way
yeah yeah kinda yeah
wow
it's like you can't even get good
friends no you're not even okay and
you're leaving now that's I mean you
know what though seriously like you
could fix this place up it'd be dope
though for real our car is going to be
able to fly or is everything going to be
on a magnetic track I mean that's what I
want to know it's no big deal this O
Negative tastes like pennies oh I'm
sorry but hey come on nipple player for
private time we talked about like 2011.
it's just a drink and when we wake up
you guys okay but do I look in the
camera no oh at you all right like on
television all right
stupid ass grab ass and tell it boy God
damn I told you they was rotten
I am a Partners Jackson principal here
at clortho
Vince clorth Ohio uh this station is
just a formality there's a bunch of
stuff that we confiscated just this week
Mr you don't have to show them that
here's a one with a silencer on it why
but I ask again why what other five
girls in this school is pregnant with a
demon baby
the babies are evil but the mothers
they're good kids as we said chlorthos
there's never a portal that cannot be
opened with Ingenuity and respect
how you're going to be using an
invisible cloak when I can see you
tagging the damn wall dime bag of pixie
dust Contraband let's see here's the
thing the kids know that the only way to
fly wizard pepper unbelievable get your
ass out of my office I will turn you
into a spider
they're good kid Hogwarts and clothos
Claw throws and Hogwarts go hand in hand
the best top two Wizarding schools there
are
but you know uh out of these two schools
we each have our strikes we do score a
little bit lower on our standardized
tests than Hogwarts but there is a
cultural bias we may not have a huge
endowment like they get over at Hogwarts
and yes some of the teachers have to buy
their own new ties or bat wings one kid
gotta transformed into a cat they can't
even afford a changing back this young
man's name is Jamar normally you're not
allowed to touch the students like this
when they're in human form
but uh when they're cat we just have at
it
spots everybody loves sports it's
everybody the hallways are a Bluster
with the conversation of our quidditch
here half the team is back here riding
mops we got two little Nicks on Swiffer
when all is said and done uh the average
chlortho student uh said this mother
sometimes the kids think it's cute to
turn themselves into a rat sneak into my
office play a little joke on me who is
that Tyrone is that is that no that's an
actual rat
still that's a waste of money dog I
don't even understand how that's even in
the horror genre dog I mean that's the
least scared I've ever been man it's
like a like a romantic comedy it's like
a lullaby dog yeah for reals no oh oh
where you parked at Ohana where are you
parked there bud yeah I'm over that way
boy are you all the way down there yeah
well I'm this way do it all right all
right dog all right
thank you
object that's too General to be scary I
mean it's like how you gonna have a
demon posted up in a trash can I mean
you know it don't make no sense it's
stupid
it's stupid it's unrealistic it's what
it is it's like I ain't gonna be scared
of no trash can
and then what was that other thing they
had with the uh the uh the demon puddles
oh yeah yeah that was the most stupid
part right there a demon can pull you
into hell if you step in a puddle like
read some morons I mean how you gonna
scare a couple adults with a puzzle
stupid
and a demon got them hellhounds roaming
around everywhere bringing humans to the
demon alive to be sacrificed oh boy
yeah you know it's like it's lazy
storytelling yes yes it's what it is
it's a lot of things but scary is not
one of them
creepy kids in the whispering and
whatnot come on dogs you just identified
like the stupidest part of the movie
and kids and Kids was talking about I
will steal your soul I will suck your
asses okay yeah let's do it right there
you can stop right now man if you just
wanted please stop
because it's stupid it was stupid it's
stupid it was stupid it's your car it's
me doing yeah
yeah I hope uh there's not one of them
demons possessing your car
laughs
right now that's stupid you've been
around
that was the stupidest part of the movie
right there dog that was pretty stupid
that was the stupidest part right there
man that part of the school I believe it
was stupid as hell
you're stupid
stupid that was the non-skilliest part
of the movie oh my God it was so stupid
I mean it's so selfish it's pretty
stupid
you know what man
I'm sorry dog did you have to watch that
dumbass not a scary movie man you know
that's how we go that's how we're going
give yourself up Carlo why would I do
that
when I have
[Music]
give yourself up Carlo
I'm right here
or am I over here
you shut up [ __ ] come out here's my ass
look big in this jumpsuit
none of the games Carlo
[Music]
the games are just beginning
[Laughter]
[Music]
mirror mirror all on the wall
who's the fairest
you are under arrest
for the murder of Mary Deeley Meg Foster
and one detective Mason Jimenez
Now where's the girl
oh Detective
you assume it's the real me standing in
front of you
but maybe that's just what I want you to
see
when in reality the real me
is safe in a hidings for her
okay that's the real you all right
or maybe I'm over here no no you're not
over there
Carlo I'm only going to ask you one more
time where is the girl go ahead and
shoot Detective
I mean what do I care if you get seven
years bad Loca you know it's not safe to
keep a gun cocked like that even if you
are just pointing it in the mirror turn
around and put your hands on your head
now for that you really are going to
have to find the real man you're kidding
me
hmm
come what why would you shoot a mirror
Carlo it's you I'm holding your lapel
now you're done it's over
you're gonna cut your hand on that
broken mirror
where is she
say it dude say what
say you don't know whether or not this
is the real me or just a reflection in
the mirror
weekly
I'll tell you what you do
okay I don't know whether the you I'm
holding on to is really you for the
reflection or a reflection in the mirror
[Music]
shoes on the before boards by the
intross
I win detective
I told you but I mean the mirror told
you but but you know
oh
hey what's up 10 in the net come on in
yes all right thanks for coming
have a bloody good time awesome oh
here he is what's up Noah Michael
Jackson
yeah that's what he does that's Michael
Jackson
oh some oh there we go there we go
all right three's the shark four all
right well Annie are you okay oh he's
leaning he's leaning are you okay all
right are you okay Andy are you okay
Annie you've been touched by a smooth
criminal oh
more kicks more closer close to your
face
no more you want to come inside
that's annoying that is very annoying
stop stop
don't do it anymore
[Music]
just keep doing the Shimon that's where
the children
that's some bad taste
this isn't don't even know what that is
Thriller eyes
what are you doing
no you cut off oh okay he doesn't slap
his ass like that so I don't know what
okay
hey
stop stop it stop it stop it
the costumes awful the impression is
stupid and played out everybody and
their mother was Michael Jackson three
years ago when he died
you died
oh
wait wait wait he died oh Noah
oh no
what no wait wait a second don't stand
and walk away
happy Halloween
[Music]